I've come together with the one on my
charity this winter bone sisters helped
to feed those who are in poor conditions
and who don't even have a clothing to
keep theirself warm your small donation
might mean nothing to you but it can
change their life and help them survive
the winter this year
brothers and sisters and dear friends
yes the title is right from the sisters
you are seeing now the britons
themselves in the western world who are
implementing the Sharia not just in
England they are implementation Qatar
how well let's read it for ourselves
this is Ellie Mollison who campaigns to
improve match the experience for women's
football supporters was so concerned
about visiting Qatar her father is
acting as a chaperone what is a
chaperone a chaperone in Islam is called
a Wali a hermahram a guardian who is
there to protect her from the process of
providing for her from the process of
when it comes to suitors marriage tutors
coming to her he's there to her
traveling he is her guardian throughout
her life until she marries and then that
Guardian is passed on over to the
husband now the film is watching this
Blood oh my gosh is the woman the
property of that man that he is throwing
her around however he likes uh no Islam
and the Sharia deals with real life
situations and real lifetime moments and
one of those is matchday and when you go
to football like a World Cup and guess
what we will have to live in a realistic
idealistic world where women don't have
to do this but Islam and the Sharia and
God Almighty acknowledges that in
certain situations and certain
circumstances that a woman needs a
guardian and as a woman is fragile and
delicate by her nature she requires a
man to protect her I mean any feminists
are pulling their hair out right now
that's fine you can carry pulling your
hair out you probably have no hair left
and you will have to travel to Turkey to
get hair transplants that's fine we've
got solutions for that and the greatest
inequality is to treat unequal things
equally that's the reason why the Sharia
has implemented and stipulated that when
a woman travels abroad her guardian is
there why because a woman is still prone
to being maybe kidnapped maybe being
harassed maybe being sexually harassed
maybe being abused maybe being followed
and God knows any kind of things that
can happen in a country that she is
foreign to a man usually is a man is
more stronger than woman so when you
have a guardian the guardian is there to
protect the woman she further said he'd
not he need not have bothered mullison
and many other female England fans say
This World Cup could create a model for
the game at home wow and then she goes
I've got to say coming here has been a
real shock to my system said Morrison 19
who runs the her game two campaign that
have been no cat calls wolf whistles or
sexism of any kind she is gobsmacked
she's like I never knew such a thing
existed the Western woman in the in in
the countries that we are living in have
been sexually harassed cat called 90 of
the figures are so high it's crazy that
a woman cannot peace when he walk down
the road without being called
um you know sexually harassed being
stalked followed and when she went there
she truly felt liberated and it's
nothing but Liberation that you can go
to a country nobody tries it with you
nobody sees you as a sexual object and
men respect you and go about their
business you can go watch A Match she
has even started her own movement so
women can have peace she's wearing
raising awareness isn't that amazing
that every single time the Western World
who always Mock and criticize Islam they
turn around and round and come back to
the same spot which the Sharia told them
from the beginning if you do this you'll
be successful but sadly the Western
World and many Muslim World Muslim
countries sadly are following suit as
well that they have to go and learn it
the hard way Islam is there as a
prevention not as a cure we stop it from
the get-go not go and do a and if you
learn a lesson and realize that you
broke your leg or lost their life and
then we can make some changes Islam says
no God Almighty knows what's best for us
and he stipulated that we would rather
follow his laws and better be safe than
sorry brothers and sisters that's all I
had to say and alhamdulillah everything
Islam has stipulated One By One The
Western world is opening their eyes to
it